Julian Edelman was not a day one starter
last year for the Patriots because he
had a four-game peds suspension to serve
he's got a documentary that is
premiering on Friday he's doing a fairly
extensive media tour we weren't included
that's fine that doesn't affect our
opinion it could be that our opinion
that he already knew about is the reason
why we weren't included Chris because he
has yet to be grilled about what he took
why he took it and most importantly
whether he knew that what he was taking
is something that was a violation and
whether he just engaged in essentially
PE d Russian Roulette and hoped he
wouldn't be tested consciously and
deliberately cheating in the name of
recovering from the ACL tear and getting
back onto the field sooner rather than
later it's still a violation right it's
still something that's grounds for a
suspension and it's still fundamentally
cheating but unlike all the other guys
that will say well like you know I got a
supplement and I didn't know that it was
spiked with a PE D Edelman has never
started down any path in trying to
explain this and no one is asking him to
do it and I don't know maybe people just
don't care I know you care the reasons I
care is every time his name comes up you
point out I can't I can't get all
excited about a guy who won the Super
Bowl MVP when he cheated yeah it bothers
me I mean it does you know anybody
that's ever followed me through my media
career to this point I mean this is
something I'm you know I'm very strong
about I don't like it yeah it's you know
it's you know not fair to guys who were
trying to play the game clean and do it
the right way and I really want to like
Julian Edelman too because I respect a
lot of the things he does but yeah this
is a guy who I liked and now I question
everything I know about him and
certainly has done you know he's been
given a free pass to a degree in my eyes
he's they've skirted yes the
conversation a lot and now he's been
celebrated because he did have that
great huh you know playoff run in the
Superbowl game and everything about it
and I get that but still at the end of
the day it's a bad example for young
kids growing up it's cheating your
fellow teammates the people you're
competing against and that bothers me so
there's a lot here to unpack but yeah he
certainly kind of gotten away without
any having to answer any tough questions
and I want
all these guys that go positive with PD
tests I wish they would make it public I
mean to me when you cheat I think that
should become public information they
shouldn't be able to skate behind the oh
I took adderall or oh I took the GNC
something but but here's the thing if
they lie about what they took the NFL
now has the ability to say no it wasn't
at all it was steroids or whatever but
they can still always throw out that I
took a supplement that had something in
it that I didn't know about how do you
prove that to be right false I mean I
mean we've really Kris they've been
testing for peds for decades now and
they've never caught anybody who was
actually trying to cheat right yeah I
thought was a bunch of poor poor suckers
that went to the local GNC and bought
something that was spiked yeah you're
exactly right about that Mike and and it
does that bothers the crap out of me I
mean whether it's baseball football I
mean I have a yeah a strong opinion on
that now
I'll say this too about this issue you
know I do wish and this is where this is
where maybe I give like Julian Edelman
the slightest bit of okay and again we
don't know and he's really never come
out and the last time I heard somebody
asked like what happened with the drug
test he was I really don't know he
didn't like he didn't even try to deny
it he kind of just was like yeah I
messed up but but I you know there is a
part of me that goes I wish that the NFL
could somehow for guys that are injured
could find a way to maybe give them some
of these more advanced
performance-enhancing drugs for a period
of time to help them heal but then you
get off I know that's a totally
different subject all right go ahead
that's a negotiation and I found the
NFLPA
either has had or would have to have
yeah bottom line is this there's no
exception for I'm recovering from a knee
no there's that's one of the main
reasons why people use peds to speed the
recovery process from an injury and look
I Julian I'm gonna won the MVP award of
this Super Bowl that's fine but you know
what maybe it should have been somebody
else Yeah right you should have been
somebody who didn't take a PE D because
that PE T I mean at the end of the day
like I said Russian roulette
maybe a little bit of a bargain here hey
if I get caught I'll miss the first four
games but at least I'll be is
healthy as I want to be and need to be
when I do come back so it's worth it
right I mean those kinds of
rationalizations and justifications that
those happen yeah they're not good I
mean maybe they take the baseball stand
where you don't get to play in the
playoffs if you get you know a positive
PE D test I would be in favor of all
those type of rules well we got two
questions that we have posed via Twitter
we rarely have to I don't think we've
ever had to usually it's just one two
questions today first is this do you
care if an NFL player whether it's
Julian element or Patrick Peterson or
anyone else is caught using peds you can
answer that yes or no on Twitter over
3,000 already have question number two
and this is an important one we're talk
more about this in an hour okay do you
see a difference between using a PE D to
get better and using a PE D to recover
from an injury a lot of people see a
difference I don't think there's a
difference
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports